Ця війна завтра не завершиться.
Можна, звичайно, тішити себе ілюзіями.
Можна тверезо дивитися на речі.
Мова не є аж настільки дійсно дражливим моментом до тих пір, доки за неї не беруться політики.
Себе в цій системі я не бачу,
вона зовсім не відповідає моєму психотипу і моєму уявленню про порядність, гідність.
Коли замовкнуть гармати, почнеться війна культур.
Саме культура буде тим майданчиком, з якого почнеться велике адвокатування Росії.
Сьогодні спілкуємося з літератором, музикантом, культурним та громадським діячем Сергієм Жаданом.
Пане Сергію, вітаю вас.
Доброго дня.
Пане Сергію, нещодавно у світ вийшла ваша нова поетична збірка "Скрипниківка",
як ви казали раніше, присвячена такій символічній трансформації української мови в суспільстві.
От ви, як автор цієї збірки, якою ж ви бачите цю трансформацію?
Там йшлося, скоріше, про ці внутрішні перетікання мови в нашому просторі, в нашому часі.
Мені здається, по-перше, змінилося саме поле її функціонування.
Мені здається, це страшно цікавий і важливий момент.
Здається, що українська мова, мабуть, вперше за свою історію вийшла поза межі якогось гетто,
і вона сьогодні, справді, є мовою нормального щоденного побутування і функціонування серед українців.
Це попри те, що далі не всі українці нею користуються щодня,
але все одно в цілому це не можна порівняти з ситуацією, скажімо, дворічної давнини.
Зараз українська, це справді не одна із двох мов, якою користуються українці.
Це головна мова, це перша мова.
Ви згадали про українців, які, попри все, ще не перейшли на українську.
А чи важлива тоді на нинішньому етапі така ось трансформація мови в суспільстві
як перехід російськомовних українців на українську, оцей повний перехід?
Звичайно, це важлива річ, мені здається, це очевидно.
І тут справа не в тому, що, скажімо, це прискорить нашу перемогу.
Мова про те, що якщо ми хочемо, щоб у майбутньому ні в кого не було підстав  нас від чогось звільняти,
ну, слід, очевидно, розібратися з самими собою і з своїми якимись пріоритетами,
і своїми якимись цінностями, і своїми цими ознаками і маркерами ідентичності.
Що ми хочемо, як ми хочемо жити, чи, справді, ми вважаємо цю Україну своєю,
чи, справді, ми вважаємо, от, власне, весь цей культурний пласт своїм.
Тобто нашу мову, нашу культуру, нашу історію і так далі.
Ми це могли зробити і в 91-му року, щойно було проголошено незалежність.
Я, власне, все життя своє працюю на цю нашу конструктивну, здорову українізацію.
Ми у місті Одеса, і станом на 2023 рік 40% жителів Одещини,
за даними досліджень фонду "Демократичні ініціативи" і зі слів мовного омбудсмена,
не можуть перейти на українську мову, тому що просто недостатньо, на їхню думку, неї володіють.
Що ви помітили тут, спілкуючись з одеситами, і як гадаєте, чому така ситуація?
Слухайте, ну я нестримний оптиміст, і якраз мені постійно впадає у вухо українська мова.
Тобто не скажу, що всі, кого я тут зустрічаю і бачу, говорять українською,
але я щойно сидів у кафе, в кафе сиділо 10 людей, і з них, здається, всі говорили українською мовою.
Ну тобто ви для себе це фіксуєте?
Я для себе фіксую, так, звичайно, це автоматично ловиться.
Знову ж таки, в мене немає якихсь надмірних ілюзій.
Я розумію, що процес українзації - це складний процес,  він не відбудеться за один день
і навіть за один рік не відбудеться.
Але те, що зміни відбуваються, для мене очевидно.
Скажімо, ми зараз стоїмо в парку Шевченка, а ось там от у нас Зелений театр.
І я останні роки щороку сюди приїздив влітку і мав вечори,
і на ці вечори приходило по 600, по 700, по 800 людей,
це одесити, одеситки, публіка, яка читає українську літературу, яка говорить українською мовою.
І для мене оце - це Одеса.
Хтось хоче бачити далі людей, які говорять лише російською мовою?
Це питання суб'єктивності нашого зору і нашого ставлення до цього світу.
Я нашу українську склянку бачу напівнаповненою.
Завжди є купа якихось емоційних причин, емоційних пояснень, емоційних виправдань,
чому людина далі говорить більше російською,  а не українською.
Як гадаєте, яким чином, можливо, силами місцевої влади  або культурної спільноти
дати можливості ось цим 40%,  які недостатньо, на їхню думку, володіють?
Та ну як місцева влада може примусити людину перейти на українську?
Можливо, якісь навчальні курси заохочувати?
Це хороша ідея. Під час великої війни, можливо, на це не вистачає сил, ресурсу і часу.
Я думаю, що так чи інакше цей процес, він не зворотній, він буде відбуватися через літературу,
через інформаційний простір, через мову мас-медіа і так далі.
Гадаєте, через рік ця статистика зміниться?
Я припускаю, через рік ні, а через п'ять років, я думаю, так.
Я цілком свідомий того, що ще за мого життя Харків буде цілком говорити українською мовою.
А Одеса, наприклад?
Ну, із Одесою будуть відбуватись якісь процеси, вони вже відбулися.
Можливо, вони не настільки кардинальні, не настільки динамічні, як нам всім хотілося.
Не нам всім, а нам хотілося. Але я думаю, що це буде змінюватися.
У 2014 році, вже після окупації Криму Російською Федерацією, ви казали в одному з інтерв'ю, цитую:
"Очевидно, що зараз не найкращий час для мовних воєн. Та навіщо їх вирішувати?
Не думаю, що нас роз'єднує мова".
Що ж нас тоді роз'єднувало і чи роз'єднує українців щось зараз?
Я завжди говорив, насправді, про те, що мова не є аж настільки дійсно дражливим моментом,
до тих пір, доки за неї не беруться політики.
І згадайте, що разом на передодні виборів питання мови підіймалося, актуалізувалося
і ставало вагомою причиною для тих чи інших електоральних здобутків.
Насправді, я живу все своє доросле життя в місті Харкові
і,  чесно кажучи, ніколи не мав проблем зі своєю українською мовою.
Так, але, скажімо так, середовище постійно було на боці російської в таких регіонах.
Книжки, кіно, телебачення.
Ну, знову ж таки, ви розумієте, що за цим всім часто була  політична позиція
місцевої влади чи регіональної влади, коли провадились ті чи інші наративи,
коли просувалися ті чи інші ідеї,  які були, м'яко кажучи, не зовсім проукраїнськими.
А натомість ситуація минулої весни показала, що Харків - безперечно українське місто,
де живуть люди, які люблять свою країну,  які люблять своє місто, які готові її захищати.
І всі ті попередні багаторічні спроби певної частини політиків витворити такий статус Харкова
як альтернативи Києву, статусу прикордонного міста, яке більш схильне до Росії
та більш прихильне до Росії…  Все це нічого не дало.
Я думаю, ми єдині, як ніколи.
Про єдність: навіть останні новини щодо заяви нашого головнокомандувача Залужного
про нинішній стан війни, яка, на його думку, переходить в позиційну фазу.
Після виходу цієї колонки у виданні The Economist в Офісі президента кажуть,
що певна незгода є з позицією пана Залужного і з його відвертістю у цих словах.
Західні партнери також відмітили, що аналітики вважають, що це про певний політичний розкол свідчить.
А як ви вважаєте, чи згодні?
Я знаю Валерія Федоровича, людина щира і емоційно дуже відверта.
Я думаю, він сказав те, що думав.
А як це трактувати, я думаю, кожен може по-своєму трактувати.
Він же сказав очевидні речі, зрозуміло, що ця війна завтра не завершиться.
Можна, звичайно, тішити себе ілюзіями, можна, звичайно, говорити,
що наступного місяця ми зайдемо в Крим і готуватися до завершення.
Можна тверезо дивитися на речі і готуватися до того,
що це марафон і нам не треба пройти до кінця, якщо ми хочемо перемогти.
Ви родом з Луганщини, нині з окупованого Старобільська.
Зараз там є якісь ваші друзі чи родичі, за яких ви турбуєтеся?
Є знайомі, безперечно. Хтось виїхав, хтось залишився. Когось посадили.
Когось немає вже серед живих, не превеликий жаль.
Там багато різних речей робиться.
Є якісь контакти, залишилися, намагаюся отримувати якусь інформацію.
Щось мене тішить, навіть в цій ситуації.
Щось викликає величезне розчарування.
Чи вірите ви в успішну культурну реінтеграцію людей, які проживали і проживають нині
на окупованих ще з 2014 року територіях, от після їх звільнення?
Це буде складно, безперечно. Але іншого шляху там немає.
Культура і освіта. Тобто українська освіта, українська школа,
українська вища освіта і, безперечно, культура.
О, впало щось!
Це був щойно вибух.
Ну що, давайте будемо проходити, я думаю, вже в укриття, кудись в безпечніше місце.
Ще у попередньому інтерв'ю DW в перші місяці повномасштабної війни ви тоді казали, цитую,
що не "бачите підстав для надмірної критики влади".
Яка ваша думка зараз після скандалів у Міноборони і різних корупційних історій?
Є, звичайно, кредит довіри, є розуміння пріоритетів,
важливості того, що нам потрібно триматися разом,
не займатися політиканством.
Але і коли ти бачиш такі демарші всередині суспільства,
коли ти бачиш, що фактично люди, які би мали забезпечувати  якусь чесність і прозорість,
є фактично першими порушниками цієї угоди, цього пакту про ненапад,
тоді багато речей і ставлення доведеться змінюватися.
Тому, складне питання.
До останнього, я думаю, не хотілося б переводити все це в політичну площину,
але деякі рішення, деякі вчинки, деякі історії викликають дуже багато питань.
Як гадаєте, зараз в Україні на часі президентські або парламентські вибори, про які говорять?
Я в принципі не зовсім розумію, як би зараз могли відбутися прозорі, чесні президентські вибори,
враховуючи, що частина території окупована,
частина територій знаходиться у прифронтовій зоні,
частина громадян знаходиться в окопах.
Чесно кажучи, не зовсім розумію зараз політичну агітацію і так далі.
А ви бачили колись себе в політикумі, можливо, після перемоги?
Ні, я дуже люблю свою роботу, мені подобається те, що я роблю, і змінювати рід занять я не збираюся.
Мені 50 років!
Я вже знаю, що я можу відчути, що я не можу відчути.
Ні-ні, я ставлюся з повагою до політичних уподобань своїх співвітчизників,
розумію, що вони можуть бути різними, розумію, що мені може щось подобатися,
щось не подобатися, але себе в цій системі я не бачу,
вона зовсім не відповідає моєму психотипу і моєму уявленню про порядність,
гідність і, в принципі, про норми комунікування.
Ну, ви досить активний музичний, літературний діяч в Україні.
І під час своїх турів, саме як музикант за кордоном, і після них ви не раз зазначали,
що потрібно зберегти можливість для митців,  для музичних діячів виїзду за кордон за потреби.
Ну, на ті ж благодійні тури, наприклад.
А чи варто дозволити виїзд, наприклад, військовозобов'язаним чоловікам і жінкам за кордон,
якщо вони будуть робити певні внески на ЗСУ?
Такий законопроект вже був у парламенті, хоч до голосування справа не дійшла.
Як ви реагуєте на такі ініціативи?
Слухайте, ну, я насправді розумію, що багатьох людей обурює те,
що хтось може виїхати, а хтось не може виїхати.
Я розумію, що людина при цьому може бути дуже суб'єктивно налаштована
і оцінювати це суб'єктивно.
Будьмо відверті, хтось не вірить в можливості волонтерства.
Я постійно стикаюся з цією думкою: "Що вони там наволонтерили?
Чи вони там на це допомогли?", і скільки б ти не показував звітів, і скільки б ти не показував придбаних автомобілів,
на когось це не діє. Тому це складна річ.
Я би на себе не взяв право вирішувати, кому можна виїжджати, а кому не можна.
Це занадто велика відповідальність.
Я от в якийсь момент відмовився від цих поїздок за кордон, просто тому, що це страшенно некомфортно.
Саме як некомфортно?
Некомфортно емоційно. Ти виїжджаєш і розумієш, що ти знаходишся  в тихій, спокійній, благополучній Європі
в той час, коли твоє місто бомблять.
І ясна річ, що в цьому є волонтерська складова, благодійна складова,
збираються кошти на них, купуються важливі речі.
Але я все це можу робити в Україні.
Ми з музикантами скасували тур Сполученими Штатами,
ми скасували поїздку в Європу, і я думаю, що найближчим часом ми будемо тут працювати.
На мою думку, нерозумно було обмежувати можливості людей культури працювати,
збирати кошти і повертатися назад.
І що негідна поведінка кількох людей не мала би ставити хрест на діяльності сотень інших людей,
які чесно їздять, збирають кошти, повертаються назад і допомагають.
Знаєте, я зараз бачу, що є частина людей, які дуже нервово реагують на словосполучення "культурний фронт".
До речі, дуже даремно вони так на це реагують.
Військо, безперечно, це наша сьогодні головна надія.
І це головний захист.
Але коли цей периметр нашої незалежності  не наповнений якимись сенсами,
не наповнений якимсь розумінням того,  куди ми рухаємося,
що ми хочемо, я думаю, ми дуже швидко ризикуємо всі перегоріти тут.
У вас є благодійний фонд.
Про перегорання ви щойно згадали:
а як зараз донатять українці на противагу тому,
що було на початку повномасштабного вторгнення?
Донатять. Українці далі підтримують.
Очевидно, відбуваються якісь процеси, трансформації.
Здається, багато хто визначився просто з тим, кому донатити,
і донатять лише тим людям, яким вони особисто довіряють.
На початку повномасштабного вторгнення це було, звичайно,
все набагато хаотичніше, в чомусь простіше, а в чомусь, я думаю, і ні.
Тому що відсутність якоїсь структури, структурованості,  вона, можливо,
десь була, призводила до певної неефективності.
Коли був певний хаос, збиралося на все, щось купувалося, купувалося не завжди те, що потрібно,
передавалося не завжди туди, куди треба.
Зазвичай, якщо ти знаєш людину добре, конкретно, то ти її підтримуєш.
Не тому, що інші неварті підтримки чи негідні підтримки,
просто тут зникає ризик того, що ти допоможеш людині, якій ця допомога не потрібна.
А бували такі випадки?
Бували, бували. От ми пригнали десь близько трьохсот автомобілів, я думаю, вже.
Іноді звертаються представники поліції, говорять:
"А що це за автомобіль, який ви передали? На ньому вже кілька штрафів висить".
І ти намагаєшся цей автомобіль знайти, намагаєшся зрозуміти, кому він зараз належить,
намагаєшся зрозуміти, хто на ньому зараз їздит.
Бувають, ну, послухай, люди різні. Люди дуже різні.
Допомогти хочеться всім, а поводять себе люди по-різному.
Але це не означає, що не треба допомагати.
Нещодавно інфопростір сколихнув один зі скандалів, не пов'язаний з вами як волонтером,
пов'язаний з вами як музикантом.
Ваш спільний з Христиною Соловій кліп  "Серце" став об'єктом критики.
Мовляв, він антидуховний, тому що в ньому є кадри зняті однієї з львівських церков
і паралельно з цим у кліпі присутні кадри відверті за участі ЛГБТК-спільноти.
Як ви реагували на цю критику і на такі закиди, на антидуховність ідеї відео? Бо ідея ваша.
Ну, я до цього ставився з великою прикрістю,
тому що я туди не закладав, ясна річ,  ніяких ні антихристиянських, ні антидуховних речей.
Мені здається, вийшло доволі атмосферне і красиве відео про любов,
про сильних людей, про людей, які не бояться бути собою,
про людей, які готові протистояти не надто втішеним, не надто оптимістичним якимось обставинам.
Це ж не були кадри про ЛГБТК.
Це були кадри, ми хотіли показати дуже різних людей молодого віку.
Але кожен бачить те, що хоче, кожен звертає увагу на те, що його зачіпає.
Тобто ви вважаєте, що якась частина українців просто не зрозуміла чогось?
Я думаю, частина українців просто читають заголовки
і не дивляться відео, про яке йде мова.
Або начитавшись якихось посилів, вже дуже заангажовано сприймають те,
що показано в відео і те, що співається в пісні.
Їм навіть не важливо, про що там йде мова,
тому що вони приходять зі своєю сформованою думкою, і думка доволі негативна.
Добре, коли люди оцінюють дійсно пісню і кліп,
а не намагаються туди привнести якусь теорію змови, якісь теорії підступу, теорії зради,
тому що все це насправді дурниці, і це насправді не зовсім чесно.
І ці всі заяви про те, що при зйомках цього кліпу були задіяні якісь політичні сили,
чи були якісь спроби обдурити священиків, насправді це неправда.
А чому такі відео, такі кліпи українці деякі, і ті самі церковні діячі не готові сприймати?
Не знаю, складно сказати.
Мені здається, що в принципі в нас суспільство доволі неоднорідне,
і в людей різні уявлення про такі, здавалося б, елементарні речі, як церква, як віра, як любов, як стосунки.
Хтось готовий поговорити відверто, а хтось не готовий.
Дуже прикро, що, користуючись нагодою, хочу сказати, що дуже прикро,
що звільнили панотця, який керував цією церквою,
тому що в нас з ним була нормальна розмова, в нас взагалі була нормальна, чесна, прозора комунікація з представниками церкви.
Ніхто нікого, ясна річ, не дурив, ніхто нікому не змінював сценарій.
Все це дурниці, це неправда. І, насправді, дуже прикро, що так сталося, дуже прикро, що церква вдається до таких кроків.
Для мене це просто незрозуміло. Для мене це щось неприйнятне.
Мені здається, що коли ми говоримо про віру, коли ми говоримо про такі сакральні речі,
ну, мабуть, ставлення між людьми в межах громади,
в межах однієї структури, мало би, мабуть, бути трішки інше.
Ну, але, зрештою, хто я такий, щоб давати поради церкві?
Ми поговорили про українську культуру, але питання російської культури для українського контексту,
так чи інакше, і для європейського контексту, до речі, також,  так чи інакше виринає час від часу.
На другому році повномасштабної війни деякі лідери держави ЄС,
як от німецький канцлер Олаф Шольц, вважають, що російська культура не може бути повністю заборонена,
тому що вона є частиною європейської історії, і, мовляв, деякі артисти російські
не підтримують війну Росії в Україні,
тож вони можуть виступати в Європі. Що Ви про це думаєте?
Ну, я думаю, що в німців це своя історія, особлива історія якась.
У час другої світової війни, коли німцям, мені здається,  дуже важливо про це говорити,
що далеко ж не всі німці були нацистами, далеко не всі німці підтримували нацистський режим,
тому що були антинацисти, були люди, які тоді виступали проти гітлерівського режиму, зокрема митці,
і що в принципі навіть в будь-якому тоталітарному суспільстві можлива ця позиція, опозиційність.
Я думаю, зі свого досвіду спілкування з німцями,
що вони намагаються це проєктувати на сучасну ситуацію,
я думаю, для них це звична якась матриця, яка полягає в тому,
що не можна дегуманізувати ціле суспільство, що є негідники, а є люди,
які навіть за таких обставин протистоять злу, протистоять несправедливості.
Наскільки ця теза, наскільки ця позиція є конструктивною і виправданою, це питання риторичне.
Мені здається, що якраз будь-які спроби сьогодні виправдати російську культуру, легітимізувати її,
далі лишати її в фокусі уваги, ну, насправді, ні до чого добро не приведуть.
Тому що ми заперечуємо одну, ну або не ми, а люди, які, власне, сьогодні намагаються адвокатувати російську культуру,
заперечують одну просту річ, вони заперечують можливості культури, її увагу суспільну і політичну.
Безперечно, російська культура є частиною самої концепції "русского міра".
І в цьому випадку вона виконує свою функцію, так чи інакше, більш-менш ефективно.
Росіяни використовують цю можливість, знову ж таки, для певного адвокатування своїх військових злочинів.
Вони кажуть: "Так, добре, дивіться, от у нас є ракети, вам не подобаються наші ракети,
давайте ми їх відставимо в бік, але подивіться, яка в нас культурна спадщина гуманістична!
Ви ж розумієте, що народ, який створив таку літературу, не може бути злочинцем і не може бути агресором.
Тому давайте спробуємо поговорити".
І очевидно, що саме культура буде тим майданчиком, з якого почнеться велике адвокатування Росії.
Цієї Росії, російської політичної системи і всього, що там відбувається.
Тому до цього слід бути готовими. Коли замокнуть гармати, продовжиться війна культур.
Ну, а ось поєднуючи ідею вашу того, що потрібно культуру нести далі в такі часи в Україні,
нашу культуру, і водночас про те, що Європа так чи інакше адвокатує певну частину російської культури,
чи погодились би ви, наприклад, виступити на одному поетичному або музичному фестивалі в Європі,
де будуть теж росіяни, які не підтримують війну в Україні?
Ні, я зараз не виступаю з росіянами і нікому не раджу.
Ми, в принципі, намагаємося зрозуміти, де ми будемо виступати,
з ким ми будемо виступати, намагаємося дивитися.
Іноді не все прослідкуєш, іноді не все можна прослідкувати.
Особливо це стосується, наприклад, книговидавництва.
Тому що видавництва друкують книги, в них є каталоги,
і ти не можеш прослідкувати, хто в цьому каталозі є.
Там може бути росіянин, ну і після цього просто прибирати свої книжки з цього видавництва.
От ви згадали про літературу, про книговидання.
У 2014-му ви казали, що українці, якщо вони пишуть свої твори російською,
в Україні, але російською, так чи інакше, вони є частиною нашої літератури. Ви досі так вважаєте?
Ви знаєте, в мене змінилося ставлення до багатьох речей після початку повномасштабної війни.
Але що не змінилося, це розуміння того, що українці доволі легковажно ставляться до своєї культурної спадщини.
Тому що зрозуміло, що питання російськомовної літератури, воно було,
і далі воно буде лишатися дуже дражливим.
І навряд чи воно буде мати зараз якесь легке вирішення.
Але крім російськомовної літератури, у нас вже є, скажімо, у нас є Йозеф Рот, у нас є Бруно Шульц,
у нас є Пауль Целан, у нас є багато інших письменників, які писали іншими мовами.
І от знову ж таки, що робити з їхньою літературною спадщиною?
Вважати їх частиною нашого духовного культурного надбання чи не вважати?
Але мова саме про російську, тому що Росія зараз агресор.
Ну, Росія безперечно зараз агресор. Зрозуміло, що зараз ніхто не буде говорити про російськомовну літературу як про частину української.
Тому що в нас війна саме з носіями російської мови.
Тому сьогодні якось оце адвокатувати, мабуть, просто недоречно.
А чому змінилася оця градація зараз більш категорично, а тоді ви допускали цей варіант?
Ви всередині якось відповідаєте собі на ці питання?
Тому що тоді я бачив різні настрої серед письменників, які писали російською мовою в Україні.
Серед них було багато людей, які, скажімо, прийняли Майдан,
які спочатку 2014 року були цілком на проукраїнських позиціях.
І тоді весь цей градус сприйняття і несприйняття був зовсім інший.
Важко порівнювати з тим, що відбувається і відчувається сьогодні.
Яка література потрібна Україні зараз?
Талановита, яка у нас і є, і класична, і сучасна.
Мені здається, що українська література і українська культура,  якщо брати ширше,
мені здається, доволі гідно відповідає на цей виклик,  який перед нею стоїть,
і на рівні матеріалу, який твориться, і на рівні текстів, які пишуться, і на рівні якоїсь громадянської позиції.
Виявилося, що наша культура доволі доросла, що вона здатна долати цей інфантилізм,
який, можливо, нам був притаманний довгий час останні роки.
І справді, мені здається, українська культура доволі гідно себе поводить в цій війні,
у цьому протистоянні цих обставин.
Мені здається, сьогодні важливо говорити не лише про війну.
Знову ж таки, мені видається, що коли ти сьогодні говориш не про війну,
а там, я не знаю, про любов, про батьківство, про стосунки між батьками і дітьми,
то це не означає, що ти ігноруєш війну, що ти від неї дистанціююся - зовсім ні.
Мені здається, що тут же слід користуватися не лише цим запитом з боку глядачів,
а розумінням, мабуть, того, що ці запити насправді бувають дуже різними.
Іноді в когось із митців може зараз з'явитися відчуття, що про щось інше говорити не можна.
А спілкується з читачем, вони говорять:
"Та ми трішки вже втомилися від цих пісень про війну, заспівайте нам щось, навіть про любов".
Часто самі військові це говорять, тому що, будьмо відвертими,
з тих пісень про війну, які з'явилися в перший рік, далеко не всі є якісними,
далеко не всі переживуть цю війну.
А якісь наші емоції з нами лишаються, якісь наші почуття з нами лишаються,
ми ж далі лишаємось людьми.
Для того, щоб лишатися людьми, нам необов'язково видавати себе за того, ким ми не є.
Мені здається, набагато важливіше лишатися собою.
Дуже дякую за це інтерв'ю.
Дякую вам, спасибі.